I will never forget February 14th, Valentine's Day of my sophomore year in high
school. It began like any other day but little did I realize that a choice I would
make that day would shape the course of my life forever.
No, I have to be honest, I completely made that up.
I don't remember anything from Valentine's Day my sophomore year in high school But
chances are you listened up. Why?
Because you thought I was going to tell a story.
Isn't it interesting how much we love stories, whether it's an enthralling novel, a
captivating movie or a story from a friend.
We listen to stories, we love stories and we tell stories.
There's something about a story that's irresistible.
We hear a story and it draws us in and demands our attention.
In fact, that's probably one reason why Jesus was so influential.
He told powerful, memorable stories that we can relate to.
The story of the prodigal son. The story of the Good Samaritan.
Any good speaker will tell you that if they want to have an impact on the audience,
they've got to tell powerful stories.
Stories are so central to human existence that it's accurate to say we are
storytelling creatures. Think about it.
Movies are stories. Songs tell stories.
Commercials are stories. Politicians compete to tell the best stories about who will
serve in office. Lawyers will try to tell the best story about the person on trial.
Businessmen sell products by telling stories.
Even kids, when they play make-believe, they play make-believe in stories.
Our lives are stories. But stories are not based on a series of random,
disconnected, meaningless events.
Stories are about conflict and resolution.
Stories universally address three big questions.
Origin, who is the character and where is he or she from?
Conflict, what is the problem? What went wrong?
And resolution, how do we fix it?
Even though stories vary on the particulars, the specific character, the setting,
the time frame, the problem and how they fix it, all stories address these three big
questions. whether a movie, a novel, a commercial, or even a personal
anecdote from a friend. All stories share this basic underlying structure.
In fact, you can't tell a story without it.
So what worldview best accounts for our storytelling nature and for the objective
structure of storytelling we find in the world?
What about naturalism? Well, the problem with naturalism is naturalism cannot
account for objective morality, for value and for meaning.
The very things that are necessary to tell a story.
Stories are about people choosing love, justice and courage.
Now of course in some stories, people fail to make those choices.
We call them tragedies and we see the pain and hurt that so often results when
people make those choices. but even when people fail to do the right loving thing we
know that they should have done it you see stories assume that there's an objective
structure to the world and that there's some choices we should make and other
choices that we shouldn't in his famous book Why I Am Not a Christian
atheist philosopher Bertrand Russell described the implications of naturalism man
is the product of causes which had no provision of the end they were achieving that
his origin his growth his hopes and fears his loves and his beliefs are but the
outcome of accidental collocations of atoms that no fire no heroism no
intensity of thought and feeling can preserve an individual life beyond the grave
that all the labors of the ages all the devotion all the inspiration all the
noonday brightness of human genius are destined to extinction in the vast death of
the solar system and that the whole temple of man's achievement must inevitably be
buried beneath the debris of a universe in ruins if the universe as
a whole is meaningless then why are we human beings so committed to meaning and
purpose and stories why do we so believe that our lives are stories and they matter
in the grand story of reality on an evolutionary world view according to naturalism
our storytelling ability is really just the result of survival of the fittest it has
survival value but other animals survive without storytelling so why do we
humans need it and further if we live in a universe of ruins
why is there even a built-in structure for storytelling in the universe
how can a chaotic accidental meaningless universe even
build the formula that's universal for storytelling what about
pantheism like naturalism pantheism fails to offer suitable explanation
for story remember on pantheism there is no mind behind the universe
and since meaning comes from a mind in the pantheistic universe there can be no
meaning and hence no meaningful storytelling further on the pantheistic
worldview as you will remember distinctions are artificial so there's really no
distinction between good and evil heroism and cowardice love and hate
so how can pantheism account for story when the very virtues that make story
possible are artificial. The monotheistic worldview seems to provide
a much more robust basis for story.
We are so committed to stories because we're part of a meaningful world.
As beings made in the image of God, our lives are part of a grand story made
by the author of life.
Our individual lives matter because they are a part of the grand meaningful story.
In fact, the texts of the great monotheistic religions whether the Quran for
Islam, the Torah for Judaism or the Bible for Christianity see our individual
lives as significant because they're a part of the grander story and they advance
the story through poetry allegory and even through history like the existence of
objective beauty and morality. Storytelling doesn't prove that God exists, but we
are examining a certain feature of reality our storytelling nature and the objective
structure of storytelling which is built into the world in which we live.
And we're simply asking which worldview best accounts for it?
Naturalism lacks the resources to adequately account for story and so does
pantheism, but the theistic worldview offers a much more promising and natural
explanation. We love stories, we tell stories because our lives are
stories and they matter and they're a part of the great story of life.